[Music]
and hell no we won't go news submitted
by the best a man can get thousands of
protesters marched to Hong Kong to
oppose legislation that would allow
people to be extradited to mainland
China and we just turned to the agent do
you want to tell us what you know
yeah so one side is like I want to do
and the other side's I don't do that
please and then that's it
wait extradited feel like we needed
subtitles yeah so pretty much what's
happening here is that the Hong Kong
government they have proposed a bill
that was first introduced in February of
2019 due to a this homicide case that
happened like this
Hong Kong couple in Taiwan and so pretty
much what they doing there this whole
bill thing is that they're trying to
extradite criminals from Hong Kong to
mainland China and Hong Kong people are
like [ __ ] no China is crazy we don't
know like they always violate it's a
cumin well they're not gonna get like
due process due process what were you
saying it so say some Chinese people who
happen to be vacationing or they're in
Hong Kong but extradition has to do with
like when you commit a crime and you're
not part of that yeah like if you commit
a crime in China yeah and then you go to
Hong Kong to escape that's exactly what
it's kind of complicated so like there's
Chinese people ethnically mm-hmm but and
government wise I think there's four
major ones
so there's China mainland China then you
have Macau Taiwan and Hong Kong and they
have their own self governing bodies
with their own set of rules that are
unique to them that they're used to yeah
and a lot of people that do business or
travel they do have multiple homes in
multiple places they live in different
areas so the Hong Kong couple I didn't
read about that part but they could
possibly just be living in Taiwan even
though they're all Hong Kong citizens
like a lot of people
multiple paths got you and in so what
everyone's is scared of is they're used
to human rights there's used to a
certain level of due process and
independence but now if they pull it's
almost like if like imagine you're a
publican right and you live in Texas and
then but you were born in California and
you do and you you understand the laws
of Texas but all of a sudden when you
commit this crime where something
happens they pull you to California to
judge you or like or even even something
that's even more like harder than that
like let's say you're used to paying
Vegas taxes mm-hmm and then all of a
sudden they pull you into California I
pay California taxes so it's like it's
like immediately like your whole world
gets shifted upside down and like all
the rules are changing yeah and that's
them so they're trying to make it seem
like just for criminals right but then
people are saying like well the way that
their wording this bill it could be I
could literally do nothing and be framed
as a criminal and now all of a sudden
I'm being sent to China and I make it
then that's gonna be a different sort of
different sort of due process there yeah
so there have been insane protests yeah
see there in Hong Kong why China like
why do they want to take them back to
China because China you remember back in
1997 whoa [ __ ] looks like yours like a
whole bunch that can okay a river so
back in 1997 China - Kong Kong back from
Britain and they gave them 50 years I
think it was two reassimilate back into
being part of China and not being part
of Britain anymore and the fifty years
is it even up yet so I think that's a
feel really really kiss yeah exactly do
we know when it's up well what's 50 plus
97 Pacific 20 47 or something so still a
long time so they're supposed to spend
50 years on the transition isn't this
step like a part of the transit if they
consider it really abrupt to be able to
just extradite people like that's not
part of the transition they want it to
slowly happen because I guess what
they're like in Hong Kong their street
signs with like English words on them so
it's a very different world even though
they're all Chinese so for them they're
feeling like this is [ __ ] crazy that
you're just gonna come here come here
grab us I'm used to all these civil
rights and now they're all gonna be
taken away from me
and China's the one that's coming in and
saying this is the rule we want to
impose what's crazy is I think the chief
of Hong Kong Carrie Lam yeah is that a
he or she she she proposed this but why
what's the incentive for them to do that
while the criminals out of the city
you're the mayor of Hong Kong and so
it's so like somebody's doing something
wrong and your whole thing is like okay
yeah send them to China but it just the
print of due process it doesn't get rid
of the criminals here and the problem is
all Chinese people are criminals I don't
know who to believe because all Chinese
people are criminals so for example like
it could be a business thing where China
is in her ear hey if you pass this thing
and I can get a lot of these and pay and
pay and get a lot of the tax evasion I
could hook you guys up with this and
that's what people are saying I'm like
there's no other and it's like it
doesn't it seems out of nowhere unless
there's some shady why would you do that
exactly why would a Texas all of a
sudden go Democrat or a lot of
California Austin go to a public out of
nowhere like there's that why are you
doing that I don't know they're also
saying like that China is kind of like
picking the people to be part of the
Hong Kong government too so they could
be in China's popular so even people in
Taiwan of Macau are scared because
really if that would happen to that oh
yeah it's gonna happen to us and by
China of Criminology just mean people
are just shady no DNA in the DNA so
you're just gonna double down on this
huh are you gonna confess so you tried
to give you a way out it's shady blood
he cuts himself hoping you see this
right here yeah yeah criminal blood he's
like here's your wallet
I didn't mean to it's in my blood
but yes so these protests that have been
happening since March like that's the
first damn that's a long time yeah so
like March 31st April 28 June 6 June 9
June 12 and keep in mind Chinese people
love to work so for them to go on a
march like this this matters a lot so
that's a lot of marching to at a certain
point is it making a difference it is
because like if you're marching since
march well we're talking about it
they're getting the world stage there's
like solidarity protests around the
world and they did say so on June 16
that's when they were supposed to make
decisions on this bill to fanned it up
suspending it she got scared I think
yeah she was like [ __ ]
yep big trouble these protests are also
they have turned violent there as there
has been a suicide like a protester
suicide where they light themselves on
fires that's when you're serious yeah so
like there was this one 35 year old man
who stood on an elevated podium at the
rooftop of this building at the shopping
mall and he wore yellow raincoat with
the words brutal police are cold-blooded
and then in the back it says Carrie Lam
is killing Hong Kong and then he put
that sign she put on a sign that said
I'm tired entirely withdraw China
extradition bill we are not writing
release students and the injured Carrie
Lam stepped down that's what the sign
said Jews and he killed himself and then
so they were like there were other
protesters that were trying to persuade
him not to jump and even firefighters
were there trying to rescue them but he
still jumped to his death and so now
he's being seen as a martyr yeah
uh-huh so it's getting crazy they really
don't trying to take oh yeah Mike but
what can I mean cuz you know America is
always getting in other people's
business but like as we sure can't
really do anything like what are we
gonna do go to war with China to save
Hong Kong or like what what's gonna
happen well we're already in a trade war
right now it's already like you know
well I mean the clothes are about to go
the price of clothes about it go away
yeah as it should because we are
trashing the planet true save it for
your rant which way hurt her psyche our
new segment what does it call it jess is
gonna do a new segment where she talks
about how shitty the world is in every
aspect is that good is there really that
good yeah you guys should have just
written it down I come up with these
Easter eggs and like coming to you is it
really though yeah that's why you should
do that here's some more photos is that
the one that was doctored cuz one of
them was doctored I remember seeing it
on the news dr. doze that went viral it
came out later that they doctored it too
they added way more people and yeah but
it doesn't matter because that time
lapse looks [ __ ] massive still a lot
of people there's still a lot of people
but yeah yeah they're saying is like
Trump's inauguration yeah yeah so this
is a big deal right now happening
I feel bad look how angry she looks yeah
well the other one
does she ever smile it's [ __ ] crazy
how do people sleep at night like it's
like a piano teacher yeah she's gonna
start red collar but like a stern one
she's like it has a ruler you know yeah
imagine the US had to all of a sudden
like bend the knee to a different
country just somebody just try it
the state can't even bend the knee to
each other
Yosemite Sam of it is
they're bended in some things you know
they are me good abortion true how do
you what are you thoughts about that
listen he's like I care about my career
that's a different video something else
likes all I news though that was kind of
funny since this is sort of a funny
channel is that port yeah the porn sites
words like shutting down and asking
people to join the protest in Hong Kong
there yeah that's not right if I'm in
mid-stroke and then all of a sudden oh
yeah
yeah they're saying if you're a Hong
Kong police officer relative we're
supporter please leave this site and
then said like you know attend the life
and death protest instead of playing on
the internet oh wow is there like a
timeline of when they like they hope to
put a vote in well that's why it was
supposed to happen on June 16th but then
they put his Hong Kong a democracy I
think so
was it like a democracy well the way
that Britain left them they are and so I
don't know how the transition was she
like an elected do they get to use all
the internet like you know how China has
rules on the Internet I feel like they
do yeah I know Taiwan does yeah so she's
a current chief executive of Hong Kong
since 2007 she I guess that like can you
imagine like not being able to get
information no like it's so crazy like
if that's so crazy to me to think like
you know like if we went to visit China
then we went on the internet and it
looked like blocked out like it look
like like the world you know it just
look like different things were really
happening in the world
yeah just submit like look at like Korea
man North Korea like North Korea they
things like there's like eight days you
know well in some aspect that happens
because Google will like not put the to
actual top search results at the top
like they'll promote whatever side they
want to promote do we know do we really
know that's so that we know everything
but what I'm saying is do you really
have
but you could like been going on like a
reddit I'm like there's this ways
there's ways to find stuff but really we
the people that so what does it matter
if some few jobs find out real
information with the mass majority is
voting and making that's not only care
about politics cuz I don't mean either I
know so many people in like the Special
Forces community and the stories they
tell me I'm like the disconnect between
what's really happening and what we
think we know so vast in looking but
look what's happening in even in the
country there's there's portions of the
country that only get their information
from certain news channels that are
swayed a certain way they don't all the
country is like that here here crazy
that's why I like the some of these
Democratic candidates they need to
actually go on Fox News and talk to
people they're controlled but they need
to do they need to try to do that and
see you know we can select sort of so
more people can get more if we could
just see a different side that's true
cuz forge a can use every time I'm
trying to see both sides of the story
I'm always like I feel like I always
find a wall like I can't get past a
certain side of the story and I'm like
what the [ __ ] and I need a VPN or
something it's because all of those news
channels are owned by the same people so
it doesn't really matter